the nura bro district in Copenhagen
a former working-class neighborhood that
many immigrants now call home
Moroccans Palestinians and Pakistanis
the area has gained notoriety for gang
violence the sound of gunfire is common
the area was home to Omar Al Hussein the
man police say went on a deadly rampage
on Saturday night
Imran Hussein is also from Nora bro he's
a Muslim activist
for decades he's been working to promote
human rights peace and tolerance here he
says more and more gang members are
turning to religion and that concerns
him
religion has become some kind of a new
meeting point for a lot of people
because they they are in search search
for some kind of identity and sometimes
they have found it in the gangs a way of
meeting each other but more and more
people also getting related with their
religion again and and trying to find an
identity within the religion the
consequences of radicalization have been
made painfully clear here in Copenhagen
police say they had an eye on Omar Al
Hussein the suspected gunman and knew he
was at risk
some people laid down flowers at the
spot where Al Hussein was shot he has
plenty of sympathizers many here
expressed approval or at least condoned
his actions this is our teachings from
from our Deen that whoever you know
insult our prophet he's you know his
judge is punishment capital punishment
and that's what that's what he did this
this young brother he just gave back
what's happening to the Muslims he
returned fire we can say doctor if you
look at it he didn't kill any civilians
I mean he doesn't care about the Danish
people it was about soldiers about Jews
because those are the people who are
killing the Muslims all the time such
views worry Imran Hosein
he says they fuel hatred in general and
mistrust towards Muslims
he's noticed a gradual shift in
attitudes towards Islam in Denmark I
feel hurt I feel sad and I feel that
people are watching me somehow
what does I'm more afraid of is people
may be using it politically to say that
either religious group or ethnic
background or are terrorists or by
nature somehow and and that will be a
saddening point Denmark has always been
seen as open-minded last weekend's
attacks
now put this tolerance to the test